la and she'll talk about optimal
transport and stephan problem
uh hi good morning everyone um
i actually don't see who introduced me
but uh thank you
and
well uh thanks for letting me speak uh
for
this problem uh even though that's not
uh directly relevant to the theme of the
workshop but hopefully you
you know
this is a new connection that we
discovered between the optimal
transport so to speak
and step on problems so perhaps
hopefully that you find some new
connections also and new ideas
okay so let me share my screen
okay
okay so uh this work uh
is joint work with young hyun kim at ubc
and uh
so young han if he was uh
going to speak then he will talk about
more about the optimization problem
but my perspective
is more about pdas so my focus is
on tds so i start from the stefan
problem so what is stefan problem
so there are two stephen problems uh
first i'll talk about the super cool
stephan problem that we are going to
focus in this talk
the second type of problem i will speak
shortly in the next page
and that's what alessio will focus on in
the next talk so the super cool step and
problem is about freezing
but not just normal water it's a super
cold water so i don't know if you have
seen on the youtube tv that if you just
google super cooling
you pull out some
water super cold water from the fridge
and you pour it and you get very
unstable and sudden growth of the ice
that water is turning into so that's
super cooling and while uh the physics
of the supercooling is still uh quite uh
not to be understood but we have a pde
that motors this phenomena
in principle which can be written
as follows
sorry what happened um
so here the important thing is the minus
sign there so that will so whether you
have minus or plus here will decide
whether uh your set here that you are
looking at
decreases in time or
increases in time so in this case the um
here the region where u is positive
denotes the region where supercooled
water sits okay so when you turn on the
time some uh either due to some stimulus
or you know
something the super cooling process
starts and then what was initially
supercooled water will turn into ice
and the equation here that's given
describes the dynamics of it okay so it
is about freezing of supercooled water
and because
it is freezing problem
it is unstable so what i mean is that as
you expect from ice crystals you expect
frackers for interface
and
it is known that sometimes if you
sort for this equation
the
freezing can all of a sudden
produce a thick piece of ice which means
that you can jump oh i think i shouldn't
mess with my mouse
you could jump this continuously over
time so the solutions are irregular
there is in general no uniqueness as you
can see
uh later
and
yeah so this problem has been studied a
lot
both in pde literature and also from
probability literature
but there is no global existence in
multi dimensions
well so that's what we studied there has
been no
result
okay
so i hope uh one more comment is that
this if you look at this problem and do
integration by parts it will follow that
the speed of freezing of the interface
so the speed of this
interface
that turns water to ice will be given as
the gradient of u
so that's
what this equation is describing
right so inside your circuit equation on
the interface it describes how fast the
interface moves that's what the pde is
about
okay
so in contrast the
the stefan problem that's more
uh
that's better behaving is the problem of
melting
so here u is not the minus temperature
of the supercooled water we talked about
it's the
normal positive temperature of warm
water
so warm water
melts and the procedure is
supposed to be smooth as you observe in
any melted region of lake or something
like this right
so uh
a simple way to describe
the difference from the freezing problem
with melting problem
is the following that if you look at
this function it's an increasing
function of u
so in this way you can vision this
equation as a parabolic equation
whereas
before you cannot this is not true
your function is not increasing
so that is another parabolic equation
whereas this one
so this one is a stable and features
regular free boundary where posts have
unique solutions for given initial data
and of course there's many open
questions
for the
regularity of the stefan problem because
still
there can be singularities due to
topology changes and so on
and this is what unless you will present
i believe in the next talk
right
so we are going to mainly talk about the
super cool stefan problem because we are
talking about wherepostness of this
problem in multidimensions which is very
well known for the melting problem so
it's more exciting to talk about the
freezing problem
we are going to study this in the
optimization with optimization structure
but let me explain how we come around
this
so uh because it's about water freezing
into ice it's very natural to consider
the solutions are given by interacting
particle system right so you think about
the heat particles starting from
somewhere
and then you trap oh
you where did it go
you travel
from
a fixed point you're a brownian motion
okay you are hit particle so you are you
move like brownian motion and then you
hit this interface where ice is and then
you turn yourself into ice so that is
the way to think about this problem by a
particle motion
so for one dimension there you know
people use this approach to prove where
postness of the problem
so i listed a few
references so all of these references
still with 1d system
um
but for malted if you try this approach
and people have tried and obtained
partial results you you see that
compactness is a big issue
and it's not even known if this particle
system which has randomness in it
has a determinist deterministic
continuous limit
okay so instead our approach you know we
still will look at brownian particles
but
with some optimization structure and
this is
this is what we tried that's new
and this turns out to be successful so
you will see that we obtain where
postness results
for the multi-dimensional super clean
stefan problem okay so that's what we
wanted to present what i wanted to
present okay
uh so first let's start with the
stopping time i'm i confess that i do
not know much probability so this will
be just as much as i know and how i
understand it
uh but my co-author can of course
answer
more advanced questions so a stopping
time of brownian motion is just a random
time prescribed to satisfy where the
markov property right so if you um
if you are at given time t and how you
decide to evolve whether stop or not
only depend on
the information given before time t
so
an easy example also how we will think
about this is given by heating time so
if you have a set
in space
s here that i uh draw with a blue color
right so as is a set you know the entire
space rn
with you know whose complement is this
round set here
then uh
you can think about brownian particles
starting inside
in this empty space and you just travel
and the first time you enter this set s
you stop there
and that's an example of a stopping time
and
if the set s is nice of course all the
stopped particles will be concentrated
on the boundary of this set s
otherwise it's not so clear
if s is just for instance only
measurable
okay
so um
our problem
is based on the
scroll code problem which is a very
popular problem it seems uh in math
finance literature and also in
probability literature
so the problem is as follows
for two about
two bounded compactly supported so that
may be just technical so uh two
probability measures mu and nu
we consider a stopping time that
connects these two probability measures
such that right i mean so this uh
how are they related you start from
distribution mu
right so you start a brownian motion uh
with the initial distribution mu and
then they treble
and then by a stopping time they stop
and if you collect all the stopped
particles and take their distributions
it's new
okay
and the stopping time has a constraint
you must
satisfy that satisfy that the
expectation of this stopping time is
finite which means that you cannot
forever sit and wait for this stopping
time to occur because if you allow that
all kinds of measures can be
achieved by this way so you want to
limit in certain way
how the stopping time operates
so this is a classical problem in
probability and it's known that such
stopping time exists for given mu and nu
if and only if
the following works oh
so the
right so this order works
the inverse of the negative laplacian is
ordered
which means what it means is that the
target measure nu which you want to
achieve at the end of the stopping times
is more spread out than mu and that's
natural because you have to start from
mu and somehow have to spread out by
brownian motion and achieve nu
okay
so that is the chord scroll code problem
it's talking about
brownian so
two probability measures mu and nu
okay
so now there is an optimal score code
problem
okay
so again for fixed brownian motion mu
and nu
you consider all
all types of stopping problem
with
finite expectation that minimizes this
cost so here is your optimization
structure
so your cost depends on the stopping
time
and uh
it's given by expectation
of
this integral
where you have this lagrangian
that has monotonicity property
okay
so if you do not
care about how it transfers from mu to
nu
it is closer to the optimal transport
right the classical optimal transport we
know but now we care about how actually
these stopping times
occur
and
okay
so this is somewhat closer to control
problem actually except that you are not
looking at a fixed final time big t
you are looking at
you know you you can stop at random
times by stopping time
rule and you want to optimize
so in relation to what typhoon talked
about
on monday afternoon
we are looking at this vanishing
particles right i mean we are interested
in vanishing particles
and actually how they uh in how they
disappear
and the law here is by starting time
okay
and the course cares about that okay so
in this case what's interesting is that
this optimal stopping time actually is
given by a
hitting time
okay so here is a hint of free boundary
problem for you right
so if you optimize this cost over all
stopping
that
starts from mu
and ends as new
then
you get a heating time of a barrier set
okay
so that is the barrier i drew below the
set s
and you can see the red particle
that starts from initial distribution mu
you travel you hit this set it which is
a space time set
and then when you reach the
boundary of s
you stop
or when you first enter the set you stop
okay so that
it's known that it's given by the
heating time
okay
moreover the optimal stopping time and
the barrier is unique so in one day this
so i mean these references there are
much more
but i
i only give a few that
that's a representative of work
so in one day uh there's mcleonar koch
swang and also yeah there's many others
and uh
the point of view that connects this
problem to optimal transport
even though mostly in one d is given by
a pedegrusman
and the pd approach is first given by
gusab and
okay so
where am i going i first talked about
the stefan problem and then i talked
about this optimization problem so we'll
see that
there is a connection
okay
so uh before i talk about this let's uh
let's uh say one more thing so if this
lagrangian is strictly increasing in
time
then the barriers are given by the
picture on the right
okay
so it is a barrier that increases over
time
so the picture looks like this
right that's on the right hand side
and uh well that's natural because if l
the cost is increasing over time then
it's better for you to move a lot when
the time is
the
at earlier times right so it makes sense
that your barrier increases over time
on the other hand if the cost decreases
in time then
the barrier opens up more over time and
you have the picture that corresponds to
the left hand side of the um
yeah
okay so the vertical axis is always time
for me
so again what happens is that this red
particles move and then they stop at a
point and then you uh
you project it if you if that's you know
you project it to the x-axis and then
you look at the distribution of the
stopped particles and then that will
become your target measure nu
okay i
please ask me if this is not
you have a question
about the formulation of the problem
so maybe
can you repeat what is l
oh l is just a second there is this
lagrangian here in the cost
right so the cost
depends on the stopping time right
so it ranges you know it counts the
lagrangian right
that
is related to the brownian motion bt as
it moves okay
until it stops
and you take you know expectations so
you take the
integral over the space
okay okay
good
anyone else
okay so we are talking about optimal
score code problem for
fixed probability measure mu
and nu
so far
and uh yeah depending on the
monotonicity
you have two different pictures
okay
so this is the question
for given mu
tau and nu
there is a barrier set right so tau is
the optimal stopping time so it's really
for given mu and nu
there is a barrier set right
associated with the optimal stopping
time
now can we understand that as a free
boundary problem that depends on mu and
nu
that is the question
and uh
okay so we'll give we'll answer this
question
so uh
to study right i mean so so far let me
just uh explain
that the point of view using brownian
motion and stopping time and the
lagrangian and so on is lagrangia
yeah so you look at each particular path
and you care about cost depending on
those paths and so on
but if you want to understand this as a
pde problem of course the natural
approach is to think about eulerian
variables associated
to it so we change from lagrangian to
eulerine
so that is not our work this was
previously done
by busup and yonyan kim and palmer
so
you can represent it by pds in this way
it's kind of interesting that i never
thought that a heat equation
with a sink term or
a heat equation with a sink term would
actually generate an interface but of
course it depends on the regularity of
the zinc term so here eta represents the
active brownian particles right
so eta is the active the distribution of
active brownian particles at a given
time
and it keeps losing particles of course
as you go because of the stopping time
so what you have lost here is given as
wrong
so row represents the stopped particles
so the first equation is
a simple heat equation with a sink
right
and the conditions are
that uh this set s barrier right
uh
the conditions is
that uh row is concentrated in the set s
and eta has nothing in s right so the
active region for eta would be the
complement of s
and of course if you collect all the
stopped particles then you should get nu
so uh and of course initially you should
be all active so
uh
is
at time zero is equal to mu
okay so that is the eulerian formulation
um
okay
so now let's see i mean uh if i can
somehow figure out what this rho is
in terms of eta then i am
very close to the pv formulation of the
problem right so far rho is mysterious
okay so can we figure that out and yeah
at least formally
so the barrier is a set of the form t
equals s of x
right the boundary of sorry not the
value
the boundary of the barrier is formally
when the barrier is very nice which will
not be the case but suppose it's very
nice
it's actually you know you expect
fractures right
but suppose it's nice and then the
boundary is given by sx equals t
and so uh
you know that's represented like that
and if you know everything is nice and
good then you expect that rho is exactly
a target measure
concentrated on this graph
sx equals t
um
right because when it stops it becomes
part of the target measure distribution
so
uh
okay so if you i mean this is of course
not directed this is the surface measure
surface measure
uh now this expression equals right
new uh
right so maybe now i don't know so here
in the last line if you
observe
that this is true right
why because the set where at is bigger
than zero is exactly the complement of s
so if you take the derivative depending
on the monotonicity of your barrier set
you either get plus sign or minus sign
but uh
okay so in this case because as the
active region is decreasing over time
you get the minus um
so that the surface measure
delta equal to the minus time derivative
of the active region characteristic
function of the
active region so
so now i can formally expect
this equity let's see what happened yeah
this equation right
so i just plugged in what happened is
that instead of minus rho i plugged in
plus
this term the time derivative term and
this is exactly the super cool stefan
problem
except that there is a weight no
okay in front of the time derivative of
the set set time the characteristic
function
okay similarly
so what is type 1 if i remind you type 1
i should just not touch this mouse so
sorry i i am trying a new computer
that's why you are seeing all these
difficulties
so type 1 is when the lagrangian is
increasing over time
so therefore you have a barrier that
increases over time in which case you
get super cool freezing problem
whereas if i have lagrangian that
decreases in time
then you have the picture in the bottom
and you have a melting problem
again both of this problem has a weight
move
in front of
the
right hand side terms
okay
and i explained to you uh i explained to
you before why the sign in front of
the new makes a huge difference in terms
of
the regularity analysis also stability
okay so so we started from the optimize
code problem and then you we arrived at
stefan problem
all right
so
the all this is formal so the question
is can you do it better can you do it in
a rigorous way and that is the first
thing we did
okay
so uh
in one day this was known
but we prove it and also in the paper
with gusab
kim and palmer it was heuristically uh
presented in the martini case where we
prove it rigorously that actually
if you solve the optimal scroll code
problem
uh for mu and nu
and you get this active mess uh you know
you you get this active brownian
motion distribution eta then at the
source
the uh
unstable stefan problem for type one
and stable step and problem for two
so that's great right i mean this is
something at least for me it's new
because you just solve one optimization
problem
to get the whole evolution out of it
which for me i mean i so far for me the
the way to think about
uh variational approach to evolution
problems was gradient flows
this is different you just solve one
optimization problem
and you get the whole evolution so
that's great
okay
okay yeah i just wanted to say that what
is actually difficult in proving such a
crm of course the barrier is
not regular
so the barrier function
or the barrier s
it doesn't have nice boundaries
so you need to show for instance
the stopped measure is concentrated on
the boundary of the barrier i mean it's
not a boundary right so it's just
you don't know if the barrier is closed
for instance so you need to
argue and show something like this
and b eta is positive everywhere in the
complement of the barrier uh it's also
not so clear if barrier is just
measurable right it can be very porous
in that case in the complement it's not
clear if the bravian particle can travel
for everywhere in the company
so you need to show nb
and then you can kind of follow the
heuristic
reasoning to obtain the stefan problem
okay so that's the difficulty
and also you can do the reverse
characterization so if you have a weak
solution
of the stefan problem with weight nu
with initial data mu
then you are going to have a picture
that's like above
so i drew the picture there
so it's a solution of a free boundary
problem so you have a free boundary
there right
now from there you can recover the
optimal stopping time as the heating
time to that free boundary
and then
yeah so they are equivalent
okay
so that's very nice except one thing
except one thing
so we would like to find solutions of
the classical stanford problem
so because that's that's uh what we want
that's what's classically uh modeled
after super cooling
and uh so if you think about what we
have proved so far it amounts to finding
uh nu as a characteristic function in
other words you want new to be uniformly
one in its support
okay
so uh for this um so so actually it's
not so easy for a given mu
to see if a characteristic function is
you know it can be achieved by stopping
times
so instead of worrying about that we
decided to you know so far we were very
successful with optimization right so
we'll just add another layer of
optimization
okay so we will what we will propose is
simply
adding an extra constraint
and now optimize also the target measure
nu
okay
so this will
you will see in a few slides that it
provides us
solutions of both stefan problems
a stable
surprising so we will see just a second
ten minutes i think
or
do i have okay
so for given absolutely continuous uh
compactly supported mu
we look for yes optimal
so the new thing is what
here
in the minimization problem
that i also free nu
but with the constraint that i put in
blue that nu
is under a given function f okay
so uh
yeah
so of course when you do not give any
constraint it's best to just stay as mu
right i mean why would you move at all
to generate cost
cost is positive
but
for instance right when i have mu like
that that's pictured in the bottom of
the slide and when i put f equals one
then
you will have to move
right
okay so that's
that's the problem
so
yeah so that is the problem
right
so you are not only optimizing the
stopping time but you are also
optimizing the target
so crm when you do this actually you get
characteristic function that's the
theorem
um
unless you instantly decide to stop so
if you look at the picture in the bottom
you have your initial measure mu
and some of them you know especially if
you're small
and if f is really just constant one
they may just
decide not to move but some of them has
to move right
and even if the mess is less than one
you may have to scoot over
to make room for the portion of mu which
is of one
so this is a non-trivial problem
but you can show
that
it's either characteristic function
or you instantly stop
okay
so now here is the consequences it's a
where postness theorem
okay
so we are setting f equals one
and to prevent instant freezing
we uh force the initial data to be
bigger than 1 so then nothing freezes
instantly
so that we get the evolution for the
entire initial data
then what you are getting is that the
optimal target measure nu is a
characteristic function
and the corresponding
active mass distribution eta
source the supercooled stefan problem
okay
within each are they dummy
moreover
what's interesting is
that this eta we obtain is the unique
weak solution
of the supercourt problem
that vanishes in finite time
so as i explained there is a high
generic
nature non-uniqueness for this problem
it's a very unstable problem but with
this additional feature of vanishing and
finite time you have a unique solution
that's given by the optimization problem
and b so
so you do not uh you cannot just uh
start from the initial support you know
your boundary will have to widen up at
the initial time and then shrink to give
room for this extra mess that's bigger
than one and so there is a
another
characterization that needs to be made
that's the initial trace
so the initial trace of the active
region is
given by this obstacle problem
that's uh
okay so this is the theorem we can
obtain
for f equals one and some of you may be
unhappy but you know this is restrictive
because i can only deal with initial
data
from a pda point of view that's bigger
than one in its support
all right
so
we can do this for general initial data
so for general initial data what i'm
doing
is that i'm just
imposing f
to be characteristic function in the
complement of the support of mu so i do
not let it freeze
in the support of mu
but i let it
freeze with density less than one
outside of the support of mu then i get
another solution
i get another solution i still get a
characteristic
i still get a
i still get a characteristic function nu
but it evolves differently right
again it spreads out
at initial time and it starts freezing
but it never freeze in the support of mu
which is k
because you are not allowed to right
your constraint f is zero in k so what
you see as the free boundary is this
blue line i draw it's
it um it narrows you know so uh it
asymptotically approaches the support of
mu
but
that's it
right it does not enter k so um and then
with this constraint you can show again
that it's the unique such solution
and
again you can sort where it starts at
the equal zero
as an obstacle problem
okay so i think that's yeah it leaves me
just a few minutes and i probably uh
yeah maybe so so
so i get this you know i showed you how
to
that using this optimization problem i
can
obtain
existence and uniqueness of this kind of
unstable problem which was quite
surprising
but it also turns out that what we
obtained through this optimization
process has
stability
um but maybe
yeah okay
so so uh for instance if i start with
two ordered initial data or initial
probability measure mu one and mu two
that's well not probability major
because you cannot
it doesn't have to be probability
measure by the way it just uh is enough
that mu and nu has the same mass
so if you start with two initial
measures that's ordered and you impose
the same
constraint f
that's not written here you impose the
same constraint f
oh here you also know one so the here f
is equal to one
then the resulting optimal
target measure is also ordered
okay
so let me point out that uh stefan
problem the super cooling one does not
have comparison
and so uh we are looking at special
type of solutions of the stefan problem
that has stability
in particular ordering property
so maybe i should just
end with one more thing
so this is the central property and
based on this you can prove
a few things which i do not probably
have time
uh but
one of the consequences is that optimal
target nu is universal
again f is the same
uh but with common f it doesn't matter
what cost you give
okay what's even more remarkable is that
it doesn't matter
whether you give type 1 cost or type 2
cost so whatever lagrangian you have
as long as it's monotone
strictly monotone
increasing or decreasing you get the
optimal target measure the same
okay so this is
very surprising
we did not expect it
but such universality
holds
and in fact using this uh we
we characterized our initial traces for
our solutions because um
right so
if the optimal let me just say one more
thing maybe then i'll just spit on
right so if you
go back and think about these two
pictures you are getting the same target
measure at the end
for both types of the picture right
and remember for the target measure
right for the picture on the right it
gives you so the target measure has to
do with the initial support of this
barrier s
which will
correspond to the initial trace of the
active region whereas on the picture
left the target measure is uh supported
on the
uh right
the
asymptotic uh shape of this uh
space-time barrier s as time goes to
infinity
so it has to do with the optimal target
there in terms of the
picture right has to do with the
sympathetic behavior of the free
boundary which is much easier to figure
out so that's how you figure out the
initial trace
for the super clean stefan using this
universality
okay so
maybe i'll finish here thank you
thank you
any questions or comments
uh hi uh i have an extremely naive
question maybe it doesn't make sense so
um
does solving a
seven problem give
is it possible to give any
numerical algorithm to do sampling for
example if you have
a target measure you start with
something very nice and then you solve
numerically solve that seven problem you
solve some the
boundary the set as
uh
the fair function s t and t and then
uh you run some particles and in the end
you stop at these particles and they
will give you the target measure
all right
does that make sense or what are the
limitations
uh do you think uh so so can you repeat
this because okay obviously i don't know
very much about sampling but maybe the
audience can give some answer could you
repeat your question
oh uh i'm just asking if
uh the idea of
self uh solving the stefan problem will
give us some numerical uh insight on
solving the
uh
yeah okay
that's a very good question i
not so
i mean so far the way we uh served it
right is to uh use score code problem
to solve stefan problem right so if you
are you you know you are asking whether
the reverse direction would give you
some insight
um yeah i mean i'm not sure but you know
as i explained that
the studying purely with pde tours the
stefan problem especially the super
cooling stefan problem right
is
quite not
it's not giving us much on the other
hand
maybe maybe
uh the melting stefan problem right the
melting step on problem which is the
picture on the right hand side
it's very well studied uh using pv tools
right
so maybe that would and there's a lot of
advances made on that problem as alessio
will explain in the next talk
so it's yes that may help understanding
the score code problem
all right thank you so much
okay i'll try to keep us on schedule so
let's think
okay
let me stop this
thank you